[Musique]
1 2 3
un look streetwear pourrait Emmanuel
Macron affublé d'une doudoune noire et
d'un bonnet les outils d'intelligence
artificielle ont encore frappé avec
cette série de photos imaginé par un
internaute probablement inspiré par le
style immaculé et inventé du pape
François une image également de la suite
de la visite d'État d'Emmanuel Macron en
Chine il s'est entretenu ce matin avec
le président chinois si jimping
notamment à propos de la guerre en
Ukraine un dîner d'État est par ailleurs
organisé ce soir au Grand Palais du
Peuple à noter qu'Emmanuel Macron est
arrivé d'ailleurs avec quelques cadeaux
notamment un vase en porcelaine de
Sèvres ornée d'une multitude de poissons
dorés ainsi deux photos du célèbre
photographe Marc Ribou
[Musique]
fait les militaires mais il était colère
contre eux puisqu'il aura sorti son
regard énervé
regardez-moi bien vous avez peut-être
des fusils mais vous ne me faites pas
peur vous m'entendez les enfants vous ne
me faites pas peur je suis un bonhomme
moi une motivation intacte pour certains
même si la mobilisation marque le pas
000 manifestants selon la police moins
que la semaine dernière et même très
loin du Pic du 7 mars un million 280 000
personnes dans les rues selon les
autorités une participation en dent de
scie
[Musique]
après un rapide briefing et la mise en
place de la sono sur le camion bleu et
les 10 il est temps pour Pierrot de
passer à l'action
et on est là pour se faire entendre
sur la célèbre musique de Rocky il fait
son entrée et est accueilli comme une
rockstar
[Musique]
ils nous disent tous et crève nous on
crie vive la grève vous pouvez me
refaire le bruit de la bombe vas-y c'est
ça
n'arrivera pas à les faire changer
d'avis par le dialogue et qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus que par la manifestation
par la revendication par cette pression
populaire dans la rue on pourra les
faire céder un sentiment partagé par de
nombreux manifestants déterminés à faire
entendre leur voix coûte que coûte si on
laisse passer ça par la suite ils vont
pas ils vont pas nous entendre davantage
ce sera exactement ce sera un rôle en
compresseur derrière de réforme
autoritaire Jennifer tout va bien pour
toi
tu déguste il y en a un qui déguste un
peu moins
bien prends des forces allez prends des
forces allez on en aura besoin pour la
suite allez
pour d'autres le bilan s'annonce encore
plus lourd comme cette ouvrière
mais après c'est un choix c'est enfin
c'est un choix enfin je le pense surtout
que j'ai pas le choix finalement elle
l'avoue sa fin de mois sera une des plus
difficiles mais une bonne nouvelle
arrive transmise par téléphone à ce
responsable syndicat merci ça va
on vient d'avoir un nouveau don pour la
caisse de solidarité
60000 euros
en fait vous venez de résumer absolument
tout ce que j'aurais dit il y avait pas
d'autres possibilités ça ne peut être
qu'un seul mais bravo qui ne se plie pas
enfin moi je serais pas venu aujourd'hui
s'il y avait pas une grève organisée
avec les syndicats donc je pense que
c'est important pour mobiliser un
maximum de gens il y aurait pas la CGT
la CFDT on serait pas là et je trouve
que l'image qui donne depuis le début
leur unité leur contribution au débat
est tellement plus sage que celle des
politiques
[Musique]
dépêche-toi les manifestants du Havre
pourront-ils tenir plus longtemps cette
mère célibataire cuisinière de cantine
était sur le point de renoncer 1100
euros de salaire deux enfants à nourrir
elle s'est fait violence pour manifester
la dernière
comme toutes les colles est en grève je
me suis dit je vais mettre en graveur
aussi elle n'exclut pas que cette
manifestation soit sa dernière
trop là elle est odieux elle me dit
encore sur une épreuve que la merde de
négoïsme incroyable que c'est encore ma
faute j'ai un binôme mais pour moi c'est
un boulet j'en ai marre j'en ai marre
j'en ai marre voilà j'ai même plus envie
de vous parler un Roissy ces passagers
ont dû terminer leur trajet à pied
impossible pour eux de rejoindre
autrement les terminaux pour prendre
leur vol ce matin
et la grève c'est normal pour tout le
monde d'accord mais dans un aéroport
international quelle image de la France
c'était épouvantable moi je suis
canadienne et je peux pas m'imaginer
qu'on fait ça dans un pays civilisé donc
aujourd'hui mais ils ont bien raison
encore faut-il que ces carburants
excellium soient eux aussi disponibles
ce monsieur est venu pour du sans-plomb
98 j'ai appelé avant de venir et il m'a
dit oui monsieur là il y en a plus
c'est fou parce que ce monsieur on l'a
reçu il y a quelques je sais pas
pourquoi on a reçu un mec qui fait son
plan
on pas reconnu Michel Jonas depuis trois
ans 11 millions d'euros n'ont pas été
réclamés que ce soit avec les grilles
aléatoires ou les grilles qu'on peut
encore remplir à la main un petit
pactole qui sert à financer les
opérations promotionnelles de la
Française des jeux beaucoup de vues et
d'interrogations sur cette vidéo de sac
à main géant roulant aux abords de
l'Opéra Garnier à Paris il s'agit d'un
montage 3D réalisé pour une marque de
luxe par un artiste spécialiste en la
matière donc on sait ouvrir ce million
d'euros mais qui n'arrive pas sur le
compte en banque des étourdi qui
oublient de se signaler comme ça
à défaut du pactole à l'Euromillions
vous pouvez tout de suite aller chercher
le pactole dans le coffre RMC vous
l'entendez c'est l'alerte on a eu cette
image du président qui s'appuie presque
se suspent à l'oeuvre de Wang youpi
comme s'il se tenait à une barre de
métro et ça dure très longtemps et les
gens autour n'osent pas lui dire
excusez-moi monsieur c'est une œuvre
contemporaine est-ce que vous pourriez
juste éviter de vous y prendre